واؤكد هنا ان تضحيات شعبنا قد وضعتنا على
طريق باتجاه
واحد يفضي الى الانتصار في هذه المعركه
والوصول الى الحريه المنشوده باذن الله
فرغم الالم وحجم القتل والدمار والوحشيه
النازيه التي يمارسها جيش الاحتلال في
قطاع
غزه بالمال وبالسلاح
الامريكي حيث ارتقى اكثر من 19000 من
الشهداء وبلغ عدد الجرحى والمصابين
الفا الا ان شعبنا لا يزال يواصل ملحمته
الاسطوريه في الصبر والصمود والتحدي
والتضحيه وافشال كل المخططات الاحتلال
العدوانيه ان هذا الشعب الابي الذي لم
يعرف الانكس سار ولن يكون للانكسار الى
نفسيته
سبيلا ولم يعرف ولن يعرف الاستسلام في
مسيرته النضالي
الممتده لن يتوقف الا بتحقيق النصر المبين
باذن الله وهذه
لقطات لصمود النساء والاطفال من ابناء
شعبنا رغم وحشيه وبطش ارهاب الاحتلال
النازي وحبلني على ارض الصم لاخر نقطه دم
في روحي لاخر نفس فيا لما يعني خلص هيك
بطل في نفس انا خليك اموت بعديها بندفن
حتى في ارضي انا بس بدي اوجه رساله
لنتنياهو بدي الله اولاد كلهم في ذا الوطن
ولا كلهم فيذا فلسطين وانا اولهم هو مفكر
ل منه بيتشطر على الاطفال هدول بده يعمل
شي هو هيك نجح مثلا حقق اللي بده اياه ما
حقق اللي بده اياه والله صامتين والله لو
اخر نفس من تحت الركان من تحت الارض
طالعين باذن الله ان تنصروا الله ينصرهم
جيش محمد جيش محمد لا يهزم ولا يخر
موجود هؤلاء الذين
يتحدثون هم الذين يدفعون ابنائهم
شهداء والذين يقتل اباؤهم وامهاتهم امام
اعينهم هؤلاء الذين يرون اله الدمار
الصهيوني
المموله امريكيا تقتل كل
احبائهم ان شعبنا الفلسطيني الذي دفع من
دمه ما ما لا يمكن تقديره بثمن بعد كل
شلال الدماء والتضحيات هذه يدرك انه لا
مجال للرجوع ولا للالتفات الى الوراء ان
طريقنا لا يؤدي الا الى نقطه واحده هي
النصر في هذه المعركه ان شاء الله وتحقيق
الح حريه والحياه الكريمه لهذا الشعب
العظيم واقامه دولتنا الفلسطينيه المستقله
كامله السياده وعاصمتها
القدس لقد فقد اطراف العدوان توازنهم ولم
يعودوا يفكر بمصير جنودهم ولا ضباطهم في
قطاع غزه ولا بمصير اسراهم بل غلب على
تفكيرهم المستقبل السياسي لاطراف ح حكومه
الحرب نتنياهو جلنت جانتس ان ثلاثي الشر
المطلق يقود جمهوره نحو مجهول اخر ونحو
احلام واوهام واهداف لم ولن تتحقق على ارض
غزه وستتحمل على صخره صمود شعبنا وبساله
مقاومتنا ان هذا الثلاثي المجرم بات لا
يابه لحياه جندي او ضابط في الجيش
المحزوم اذ يصل هؤلاء الضباط يوميا الى
الكيان قتلى وجرحى واشلاء
ومعاقين ومرضى
نفسيين ولعل في الساعات القادمه ما تعلنه
كتائب القسام عن مجريات الساعات الاخيره
من المواجهه كما ان هذا الثلاثيه الفاشل
لا يابه ايضا لحياه الاسرى لدى المقاومه
اذ يواصل قصفه الهمجيه المتواصله على سكان
قطاع غزه ويعرض حياتهم للخطر في كل لحظه
ان رسالتنا لؤلا لعائلات هؤلاء الاسرى
واضحه ان ازمت تكمن في
نتنياهو ومجلس حربه ثلاثي الرؤوس فهو الذي
باستمرار عدوانه يعطل خروج الاسرى ويتحمل
مسؤوليه ذلك ان اردتم عودتهم سالمين فافهم
نتنياهو ان المقاومه لن تنكسر وان الصدق
فيما تقول وما تفعل
فقط ويختم هذا الجيش المهزوم خيبته
بمحاولات عبثيه لتقليد المقاومه ويصور
انجازاته بطريقه مضحكه يطلق النار على
الجدران يقتحم المناطق الفارغه ينتصر على
نفق مهجور منذ اكثر من شهرين بعد ان تم
استخدامه مره واحده يوم الحقت المقاومه
اكبر هزيمه استراتيجيه وهزت بها كيان
الاحتلال ولا يعرض الا لتسجيلات لا معنى
عسكريه لها اننا نؤكد هنا ان اداره بايدن
شريكه في الحرب على غزه تعطل وقفها بشكل
دائم وتمنع تعليقها لادخال المساعدات
اذ طلبت هذه الاداره
تاجيل انعقاد مجلس
الامن واقرار القرار المقدم اليه والذي
ينص على تعليق العدوان الصهيوني على شعبنا
الفلسطيني وضمان وصول المساعدات بطريقه
امنه اليه دون اي اعاقه ان هذه الاداره
باستخدامها الفيتو وطلب تاجيل اعتماد هذا
القرار وتعطيل انعقاد مجلس الامن ستظل
شريكه في حرب الاباده التي يرتكبها
الاحتلال ضد المدنيين من ابناء شعبنا في
قطاع غزه وانها ما لم تعمل على لجم ووقف
هذا العدوان وتوقيف ارسال الاسلحه
والذخائر اليها عبر الجسور الجويه ستكون
مسؤوله مسؤوليه كامله اخلاقيا وقانونيا عن
كل ما يرتكب من جرائم ان استمرار هذه
الاداره في ترديد دعوتها للاحتلال الى
حمايه المدنيين من الاذى وتمكين المساعدات
الانسانيه الى غزه ما هو الا شعار اعلامي
فارغ لا قيمه له يحاول امتصاص غضب
الجماهير وغضب العالم في ظل دعمها الكامل
لهذا الاحتلال النازي في حرب اباده جماعيه
وجرائم حرب ممنهجه ضد المدنيين والابرياء
وهنا نقول وبكل وضوح لبايدن وادارته انتم
شركاء في الجريمه وايديكم غارقه في دماء
النساء والاطفال في غزه وستكون هذه الدماء
لعنه تلاحق الى الابد وان دعمكم للاحتلال
الصهيوني ماليا وعسكريا امنيا
واستخبارات بنيكم رواياته الكاذبه ودعايته
السوداء
لن يفلح في تغيير حقائق الارض والتاريخ
فهو كيان محتل فاشي مارس ويمارس ابشع
الجرائم والمجازر بحق شعب اعزل منذ سبعه
عقود او يزيد مما يجعلكم شركاء في هذه
الجريمه
النازيه اننا في ظل العجز امام الصمود
الاسطوري لشعبنا
ومقاومتنا نلحظ انه لم يبقى امام الغزه
سوى تكثيف المجازر والمحارق وتنفيذها ضد
المدنيين من ابناء شعبنا بايد صهيونيه
اسرائيليه امريكيه ومؤخرا يلتحق بها
الجانب البريطاني فاليوم
صباحا نشر جيش الاحتلال تسجيلا لتدمير 56
مبنى مدنيا في حي الشجاعيه في قطاع غزه
هذه هي لقطه تفجير المباني التي كان
يصاحبها
حديث لضابط من اللواء 828 في جيش الاحتلال
يقول السلام على الشجاعيه من هنا يبدا
النصر من
[موسيقى]
هنا من هنا يبدا النصر وفق وهمكم من هنا
تبدا
هزيمت امام مراه ومسمع العالم الصامت
المتخاذل في وقف هذه الجريمه وهذه الحرب
النازيه ستكون هذه الجريمه وسواها وصمه
عار على كل الداعمين للكيان
والصامت
والمتقاعدات
كبها الاحتلال ندعو المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لل قيام بواجباتها وملاحقه مرتكبي
هذه الجريمه وقيادتهم السياسيه
والعسكريه ونشدد هنا على المسؤوليه
التاريخيه والقانونيه التي تقع على عاتق
المنظمه الدوليه للصيب الاحمر ووكاله
الاونروا التي نتساءل عن اسباب عجزها في
اغاثه اللاجئين والنازحين في مدارس الانرو
والاشراف على رعايتهم وحمايه المستشف فيات
والمراكز الطبيه من استهداف الاحتلال اننا
ندعو وكاله الاونروا ومنظمه الصحه
العالميه الى العمل على تجاوز كل قيود
وعراقيل الاحتلال التي يحاول فرضها على
المجتمع الدولي وان تمارس دورها في حمايه
اللاجئين والنازحين واغاثه في المدارس
ومراكز الايواء خصوصا في مناطق شمال قطاع
غزه الذي بات يفتقد لادنى مق ومات الحياه
من ماء وغذاء ودواء وترتكب فيه المجازر في
كل لحظه وهنا نسلط الضوء على وضع الاسرى
الذين اختطفهم الاحتلال الصهيوني النازي
مؤخرا من قطاع
غزه اختطفهم من مراكز الايواء واختطف من
المدارس والمستشفيات ويزعم انهم معتقلون
من القسام وطبق هذا الجيش النازي عليهم ما
تعلمه مؤخرا من خبرات وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اذ قاموا بتعريتها وعصب اعينهم
لايام طويله ونقلهم الى قاعده عسكريه في
بئر السبع هي نسخه عن جونتنامو الذي تحتفظ
الولايات المتحده ببراءه الاختراع فيه حيث
بقي هؤلاء الاسرى والمحتجزين في الاغلال
محرومين من الطعام والشراب والنوم لفترات
طويله محتجزين باقفاص في العراء لا يعرف
احد عن مصيرهم شيئا هذه افادات ادلى بها
من جرى الافراج عنهم مؤخرا علاوه على ذلك
فان الاحتلال يقترف جريمه بشعه عند
اقتحامه بيوت المواطنين العزل اذ ينفذ
اعدامات ميدانيه يرتكبها بحق الرجال
والشباب امام افراد عائلاتهم من النساء
الاطفال لا يكتفي بارتكاب الجريمه بل
يرتكبها امام شهود عيان متحديا بذلك
العالم باسره حول ذلك نؤكد ما يلي ان هذا
الجيش النازي يؤكد بتصرفاته انه عصابه او
ميليشيا منفلت من كل القيم والمبادئ
الانسانيه والبشريه باقتياد مدنيين ابرياء
من مراكز النزوح والايواء والاستفراد بهم
في عمق الصحراء ان هذه الجرائم الصهيونيه
باعتقال المدنيين العزل من ابناء شعبنا
وتعذيبهم وانتزاع اعترافات منهم هي جرائم
تشبه تماما جرائم ارتكبت في سجني
جوانتنامو وابو غريب سيء الذكر وكانها
الخبره الوحيده التي ينقلها الجيش
الامريكي للكيان الصهيوني خبره القتل
والتدمير
والاساءه احتقار حقوق الانسان اننا نحمل
الاحتلال الصهيوني المسؤوليه الكامله عن
حياه المعتقلين جميعا ونؤكد ان اصرار
الاحتلال على عدم الافصاح عن مصيرهم يعني
ان هناك قرارا
بالاستفراغ جريمته بحقهم اننا هنا ندعو كل
المؤسسات الحقوقيه والانسانيه في العالم
الى التحرك الفوري
والعاجل في فضح جرائم هذا الاح تلال
وانتهاكاته الفظيعه وتجريم افعاله ضد
المدنيين من ابناء شعبنا والكشف عن ظروف
اعتقالهم والضغط على الاحتلال بكل الوسائل
الافراج الفوريه عنهم والعمل على تقديم
هؤلاء المجرمين لمحاكم جرائم الحرب اننا
في هذا السياق نثمن مجددا الموقف الشجاع
والجريئ والمقدره لاشقائنا في اليمن في
القوات المسلحه وانصار الله موقفهم في منع
مرور السفن الصهيونيه في ظل حرب الاباده
والتجويع والتعطيش المستمر ضد شعبنا في
قطاع غزه ونعتبر ان الاعلان الامريكي عن
تشكيل قوه بحريه دوليه في جنوب البحر
الاحمر يعد امعانا واصرار من بايدن
وادارته على قتل شعبنا بالاله الحربيه
والقذائف الامريكيه من جهه وقتله بسلاح
التجويع ومنع الغذاء والدواء عن ابنائه من
جهه اخرى
ونؤكد ويؤكد هذا هذا الرئيس انه في اطار
دفاعه عن الكيان الصهيوني يغفل عن ادراك
اراده ابناء امتنا واصرار المجاهدين
والمقاومين فيها واحرار العالم كافه على
الانتصار لفلسطين وغزه والمقاومه ويتجاهل
الحقيقه ان سلوكه هذا لن يردع انتصارهم
لفلسطين ومقاومتها بل ان هذا السلوك يكشف
وجهه الحقيقي الذي لا يعترف بحقوق الانسان
ولا بكرامه البشر عندما يكون العدو الكيان
الصهيوني ان سلوكه هذا يدفع كل القوى
للمواصله في دربها درب المقاومه ودعمها
حتى التحرير اننا ندعو بقيه الدول مشاركه
في هذه القوه الى اعاده النظر في هذا
القرار الذي يشكل تواطؤا مكشوفا ومشاركه
مباشره في حرب الاحتلال وجرائمه النازيه
ومجازره البشعه ضد ش شعبنا الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه ان على الاداره الامريكيه
الداعيه والراعي لهذا التحالف وكل الدول
المشاركه فيه ان تدرك ان جذر المشكله
اساسها هو في وجود الاحتلال واستمراره على
ارضنا وعليهم جميعا مسؤوليه وقف جرائم
وعدوان هذا الاحتلال وانهاء وجوده على
ارضنا بدلا من تاسيس تحالف
سيهدد الامن والاستقرار في الاقليم ولن
يجلب خيرا لهذه
المنطقه نعبر كذلك عن تثمين وتقديرنا
لقرار الحكومه الماليزيه منع السفن
الصهيونيه والسفن الذي ترفع علم دوله
الاحتلال الصهيوني من الرسو في موانئها
باثر فوري ومنع اي سفينه متجهه الى الكيان
الصهيوني من تحميل البضائع من الموانئ
الماليزيه ونعد هذا القرار تعبيرا حقيقيا
عن وقف ماليزيا حكومه وشعبا مع صمود شعبنا
ونضاله المشروع وهنا ندعو دولنا العربيه
والاسلاميه الشقيقه الى اتخاذ خطوات
مماثله تجسيدا لقيم النخوه والنجده
والشهامه في الانتصار لدماء وتضحيات والام
اهلنا في قطاع غزه الذين يدافعون عن
حريتهم وكرامتهم واستقلالهم وتجسيدا ايضا
لاحترام الامن والنظام العالمي كما نوجه
الدعوه الى نقابات العمال لا سما نقابات
عمال الشحن والنقل والموانئ في العالم
اجمع لرفض التعامل مع سفن الكيان الصهيوني
والسفن التجاريه المبحره اليه ورفض
تحميلها بالبضائع او تزويدها بحاجاتها من
الوقود والطعام ختاما ندعو بالرحمه
للشهداء شهداء شعبنا شهداء المقاومه على
طريق تحرير القدس في كل مكان تشتبك فيه
المقاومه مع الاحتلال وندعو بالشفاء
للجرحى والمرضى ونصر قريب باذن الله
لشعبنا الصابر المرابط ولمقاومة